Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good and to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever.
嗨，我叫贝丝（Beth），是一名来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康执业人员。我只想对《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书的撰稿人们表达最诚挚的谢意。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，并很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾一度开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理临床博士学位，但这确实给了我迈出这一步所需的信心，因此我致以最衷心的感谢。
Medically retired at 40, trainee clinical psychologist at 47. Claire's story is one of reinvention, resilience and doing the impossible, landing a place on the doctorate in clinical psychology on her first ever application. If you've ever questioned whether it's too late for you to chase your dreams or feared that you don't fit the mold, this episode will show you exactly why that thinking needs to change. Hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Some of my most popular content on YouTube has been that of older applicants. Whilst you mention YouTube, if you don't already like and subscribe, please do take a moment to do that now.
40岁时因病退休，47岁成为临床心理学博士生。克莱尔（Claire）的故事是一个关于重塑自我、展现韧性以及化不可能为可能的传奇，她在人生中首次申请临床心理学博士学位就成功被录取。如果你曾怀疑现在追逐梦想是否为时已晚，或者担心自己不符合既定模具，这一集将确切地向你展示这种思维为什么需要改变。希望你觉得这一集超级有用。嗨，欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家播客”（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marian Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我在YouTube上最受欢迎的内容之一就是关于较年长申请者的。顺便提到YouTube，如果你还没点赞和订阅，请花一点时间现在就去做。
Today's episode is helping us take a look at an old applicant. She is 47 currently and has just gained a place as a trainee clinical psychologist. It is a fascinating episode. We do discuss issues around suicide, around traumatic workplace settings, around prison. So if you are around young ears or you think that maybe now is not the most appropriate time for you to look after yourself, please do feel free to come back to this episode at a later stage. Hope you find it really useful and I'll catch you on the other side. So Claire Dunn, welcome along to the podcast and congratulations on becoming an incoming
今天的这一集节目将带我们了解一位资深申请者。她目前47岁，刚刚获得临床心理学博士生名额。这是一个非常迷人的故事。我们确实讨论了围绕自杀、创伤性工作场所环境以及监狱等议题。因此，如果你身边有小孩子，或者你认为现在可能不是照顾自己情绪的最佳时机，请随时在稍后的时间再来收听这一集。希望你觉得它真的很有用，我们稍后再见。那么，克莱尔·唐（Claire Dunn），欢迎来到本播客，并祝贺你成为即将入学的...
trainee clinical psychologist. Thanks for inviting me. Yeah, it's such a privilege to be invited to come along and join you today. Well, we've got chatting on LinkedIn, didn't we? And your story is not typical and I love it. Because actually you had a successful career in the police. you rose to the level of police sergeant and I hope it's okay to say that your current age is let me say you say your current age how old are you Claire? I'm very proudly 47. Okay so you've had a great amazing so you've had a career in the police and then obviously at some point you thought no I think maybe psychology is actually where I want to be could you talk us talk us through some of that Claire? Yeah, so I joined the police at 20. I really didn't really know what I wanted to do. I
临床心理学博士生。谢谢你邀请我。是的，很荣幸今天能应邀前来与你交流。嗯，我们在领英（LinkedIn）上聊过，对吧？你的故事很不寻常，我非常喜欢。因为实际上你在警方拥有过成功的职业生涯。你晋升到了警长（police sergeant）级别，我希望这样说没问题吧，你目前的年龄是——让我说说看，你来说说你目前的年龄，克莱尔，你多大了？我非常自豪地宣布我47岁。好的，所以你经历过非常棒、非常了不起的事情，你在警察队伍中工作过，然后显然在某个时刻你认为，不，我想也许心理学才是我真正想去的地方，克莱尔，你能给我们讲讲这其中的一些经历吗？好的，我20岁时加入了警察队伍。我当时真的不知道自己想做什么，我...
wasn't a child that grew up, wanted to be a police officer. If I'm honest, I wanted to be a Blue Peter presenter. And at the age of 20, I kind of thought that's unrealistically going to happen. And I had a friend joined the police and I really was excited by the things she was doing and the riot training. And I thought, well, I'll give that a whirl. applied and I got in straight away, which I was really quite surprised about, if I'm honest. So at 20, I started my police career. At the age of 27, I was promoted to police sergeant and I worked predominantly response. So your blue lights, your urgent jobs.
并不是那种从小就想成为警察的孩子。说实话，我曾想成为一名《蓝彼得》（Blue Peter）节目主持人。到了20岁时，我转念一想，觉得那不太可能会实现。然后我有一个朋友加入了警察局，她所做的事情以及防暴训练让我感到非常兴奋。我想，好吧，我也去试试看。我申请了，结果一下子就被录取了，说实话，这让我感到非常惊讶。所以在20岁时，我开始了我的警察生涯。27岁时，我晋升为警长，主要负责出警工作。也就是你的蓝灯出警、紧急任务。
I specialised also in child video interview. so children who were witnesses of victims of crime, custody. I did a stint as custody sergeant, which I enjoyed very much. And I completed 18 years service. However, towards the end of my service, it became apparent that my mental health had been quite severely impacted by some of the trauma that I'd been exposed to through the incidents that I'd attended.
我还专攻儿童视频访谈，即作为犯罪目击者或受害者的儿童，以及拘留工作。我曾担任过一段时间的拘留警长，我非常喜欢这份工作。我完成了18年的服务。然而，在我的服务生涯接近尾声时，显而易见的是，我的心理健康受到了我所处理的事件中接触到的一些创伤的严重影响。
And there were maybe four or five incidents, that I kind of had, you know, reoccurring thoughts about and struggled to process. Unfortunately, a decision was made that I needed to be medically retired. I was diagnosed with PTSD as a result of attending those incidents. And unfortunately, my career came to quite an abrupt end at the age of 38. And I found myself, having finished one career, wondering what I was going to do next. I was very clear. I didn't want my life to be defined by a job I once did.
大约有四五起事件，我脑海中一直有（你知道的）挥之不去的想法，并且很难去消化它们。不幸的是，最终做出了我需要因病退休的决定。由于处理了这些事件，我被诊断出患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。不幸的是，我的职业生涯在38岁时戛然而止。我发现自己结束了一份职业后，在思考接下来要做什么。我很清楚，我不想让我的生活被曾经做过的一份工作所定义。
And it was really important to me that I had a second identity. Very few police officers go on to do anything else. Once a police officer, always a police officer. And that was very much the narrative and the culture from which I came from. And at 38, I had a medical pension. I could have, you know, kept it there. but I decided, no, I wanted, it was really important to me to have a second really meaningful career in which to live out the rest of my life with. I'm not someone that wants to retire at 65 or I'm very much working is part of who I am and my identity.
对我和我来说，拥有第二个身份非常重要。很少有警察会去从事其他任何工作。一旦成为警察，终身都是警察。这很大程度上是我所出身的那个环境的话语体系和文化。在38岁时，我拥有了医疗养老金。我本可以（你知道的）把它就放在那里，但我决定，不，我想要——对我来说，拥有第二个真正有意义的职业，来度过我余下的生命，这是非常重要的。我不是那种想在65岁退休的人，工作在很大程度上是我个人的一部分，也是我身份的一部分。
But it needed to be something equally as meaningful. Yeah, well, thank you, you know, on my heart. with the great British public for the service that you provided in policing it's not an easy job and it is you know very nuanced it's very important but it also it does have an impact and actually medical retirement is not uncommon I've experienced in police services but also nor does it come without you know great levels of sometimes shame and regret and blame and kind of sadness about that because people have often really enjoyed working in the police and that part of their identity. And so when medical retirement is kind of first mooted, that sometimes feels quite challenging in itself.
但这需要是一项同样有意义的事业。是的，好吧，发自内心地感谢你，为了你为治安工作所提供的服务，代表伟大的英国公众感谢你。这不是一份轻松的工作，而且（你知道的）非常微妙，非常重要，但它也确实会产生影响。实际上，因病退休在警察部门并不罕见，我也经历过，但这往往也伴随着（你知道的）很大程度的羞耻、遗憾、责备以及对此类事情的某种悲伤，因为人们通常真的很喜欢在警察局工作以及他们在那里的那部分身份。因此，当医疗退休首次被提出时，这有时本身就会让人感到相当具有挑战性。
And we probably could do another whole episode on that, and maybe we will in future. But how did you then begin to think about psychology? So I studied psychology at a level. I'd always really enjoyed it. I was always been fascinated by human behaviour. And as a police officer, I, unlike many of my colleagues, I did look beyond the offender. And I always wanted to understand, I had this real innate desire to understand how offenders came to be where they were at that point in time. What was their backstory?
我们或许可以就此做另一整期节目，将来也可能会这样做。但是，你后来是如何开始考虑心理学的呢？我A-level（高级水平考试）学的是心理学。我一直真的很喜欢它。我一直对人类行为着迷。作为一名警察，与我的许多同事不同，我确实不仅仅局限于罪犯本身。我总是想去了解，我有一种真正的内在渴望，想要了解罪犯是如何走到他们当时那个时间点的。他们的背景故事是什么？
I don't believe people are born mad or bad. there is always a backstory and working in custody and as a police constable, I would spend a lot of time conducting constant supervisions with detainees within custody to safeguard them because they were a risk to themselves. There was either a suicidal or a self-harm risk. So I could spend upwards of 10 hours a day, literally sat outside a cell and talking with offenders, young and old. And it became really apparent that there was a trauma theme that ran through pretty much every offender I met. And that trauma then translated into substance misuse, so be it drugs, alcohol. They became incredibly vulnerable, in particular the females that I encountered, and in turn turned to offending behaviour.
我不相信人天生就是疯狂的或坏的。总是有其背后的故事。在拘留所和作为一名警员工作期间，我会花大量时间对拘留所内的被拘留者进行持续监督，以确保他们的安全，因为他们对自己构成了风险。要么存在自杀风险，要么存在自残风险。所以我可能会花长达10天（应为10小时）的时间，字面意义上坐在牢房外，与年长和年轻的罪犯交谈。而且很明显，我遇到的几乎每个罪犯身上都贯穿着一个创伤主题。这种创伤随后转化为药物滥用，无论是毒品还是酒精。他们变得非常脆弱，尤其是那些我遇到的女性，反过来又转向了犯罪行为。
And it was this cycle that was perpetuated by the trauma that they had experienced. But as a police officer, it's a very punitive role, and there is no opportunity, really, to kind of support in any type of rehabilitation. So when I came out of the police and I was medically retired, I thought again about psychology and mental health specifically. I attended more attempted and completed suicides than I can recall. The number was so devastating, actually. And I can talk a little bit about some of those experiences later. But I felt quite drawn to mental health and improving the lives of others that were struggling with mental health.
正是这种由他们所经历的创伤所延续的循环。但作为一名警察，这是一个非常惩罚性的角色，实际上没有机会去支持任何类型的康复。因此，当我离开警察局并因病退休时，我再次想到了心理学和专门的心理健康。我出席处理过的未遂和已遂自杀事件比我能记起的还要多。事实上，这个数字太令人痛心了。我稍后可以谈谈其中一些经历。但我发现自己相当倾向于心理健康，并希望改善那些与心理健康做斗争的的其他人的生活。
And we know that offending behaviour and mental health go hand in hand. Trauma and mental health and offending behaviour also go hand in hand as well. So on a whim, and literally on a whim, late. On August, I decided to sign up for the Open University psychology degree that started the following month. And it really was on a whim. I had done a degree. I made the decision to go straight into the police rather than do a degree. I was meant to do primary school teaching and I changed my mind at the last minute and didn't go.
我们知道犯罪行为和心理健康是密不可分的。创伤、心理健康和犯罪行为也同样密不可分。因此，在一时兴起之下，字面意义上的一时兴起，在八月下旬，我决定注册开放大学（Open University）的心理学学位，该学位在次月开学。这真的是一时兴起。我曾经读过一个学位。我当时决定直接加入警察队伍，而不是去读学位。我本来应该去读小学教育的，但在最后一分钟改变了主意，没有去。
So on a whim, I signed up for the degree and that's where it all started. Amazing. And we'll perhaps hear a bit more about your experiences and kind of flexible learning and self, kind of self-paced learning often a little bit later. But I just wanted to pick up on what you'd said about, you know, the prison service and the justice services being full of traumatised people. And it's so incredibly true. And if people want to learn more about that, I would really recommend an incredible book by Chris Dorr, QC, which is called Justice on Trial. Such an interesting book. And I might have. well, reach out to Chris and see if you'll come and talk to us on the podcast because it's such
所以在一时兴起下，我注册了学位，一切就是这样开始的。太棒了。我们稍后也许会听到更多关于你的经验、灵活学习以及自主学习的内容。但我只想谈谈你刚才所说的话，关于监狱服务和司法服务充满了受过创伤的人。这真是令人难以置信的真实。如果人们想了解更多关于这方面的知识，我真的会强烈推荐一本由克里斯·多尔（Chris Dorr, QC）撰写的不可思议的书，书名叫《正义受审》（Justice on Trial）。这是一本非常有趣的书。我可能（嗯）会联系克里斯，看他是否愿意来我们的播客做客，因为这是一个如此...
an interesting topic. And I'm intrigued about, you know, before you started your undergrad with the OU, did you have any relevant experience roles working in kind of mental health? So shortly, shortly after I was medically retired and once I was well again, having received quite intense CDT therapy. I made the decision to start working with young people in alternative education. So I worked for an alternative education provision, which are very similar to what were known as Prue, so pupil referral units. So their settings that provide alternative education for young people that are unable to access full-time mainstream education due to a number of enduring issues, including mental health issues and challenging behaviour arising from trauma.
有趣的话题。我很感兴趣的是（你知道的），在你开始在开放大学攻读本科之前，你是否有任何相关的经验或在心理健康领域工作的角色？所以，在我因病退休后不久，一旦我接受了相当密集的认知行为疗法（CBT）并再次恢复健康，我做出了一个决定，开始在替代教育中与年轻人一起工作。因此，我为一家替代教育机构工作，这与被称为普鲁（PRU，即学生转衔教养学校）的机构非常相似。这些机构为那些由于多种长期问题（包括心理健康问题以及由创伤引起的具有挑战性的行为）而无法获得全日制主流教育的年轻人提供替代教育。
I worked predominantly with looked after children. I did that for five and a half years in total, and I worked in that setting on a part-time basis alongside my degree with the Open University. So I feel that it gave me a lot of experience, and I was able to really reflect on what I was learning within the content of the psychology degree and kind of reflect and put that into practice with working with these young people. So really, really super helpful. Amazing. And how long did it take you to do your undergrad degree? And a question I always wondered, do you still get like an in-person graduation, even though it's kind of all remote? You do. You do. And actually, that great.
我主要与受关注儿童（looked after children）一起工作。我总共做了五年半，并且在开放大学攻读学位的同时，以兼职的形式在那个环境中工作。所以我觉得这给了我很多经验，我能够真正反思我在心理学学位内容中所学到的东西，并将其反思并付诸实践，应用到与这些年轻人的合作中。所以真的、真的很超级有帮助。太棒了。你花了多长时间完成本科学位？还有一个我一直想知道的问题，即使这种学习全都是远程的，你仍然能参加像线下的毕业典礼吗？是的，你可以。而且实际上，那真的很棒。
graduation was something I held in mind. My best friend had completed her teaching degree with the Open University before. And I remember her on her graduation walking across the stage at the Barbican Theatre in London. And on those really difficult days, nights, early hours of the morning, when I'm trying to meet deadlines of assignments, it was that I really held in mind. So the degree in total on a part-time base, is six years. However, in year one, there is the opportunity where you can kind of do two modules immediately after each other. So whereas you would normally work from October, the course would start and you would normally finish at the start of June, I have the opportunity to complete the second module, which is the equivalent of the second year by starting that. I think I started that in around March and that went all the way through to the end of September. So in that first year, I had about four months where I overlap two modules and that was really, really challenging in terms of time. When I started my degree, my children were 11 and 13. So I was still very much
毕业典礼是我一直记在心里的事情。我最好的朋友以前在开放大学完成了她的教育学位。我记得她在毕业典礼上走过伦敦巴比肯艺术中心（Barbican Theatre）舞台的情景。在那些非常艰难的日子、夜晚、清晨，当我试图赶作业的截止日期时，正是这个情景一直记在我的心里。因此，以兼职为基础的学位总共需要六年。然而，在第一年，有一个机会可以让你紧接着做两个模块。所以，虽然你通常会从10月开始，课程通常在6月初结束，但我有机会通过开始第二个模块来完成第二个模块（相当于第二年）。我想我大约在3月开始，一直持续到9月底。所以在第一年里，我有大约四个月的时间重叠了两个模块，从时间上来说，这真的、真的很具有挑战性。当我开始攻读学位时，我的孩子分别是11岁和13岁。所以我很大程度上仍然...
a mum and the commitments of all the clubs and, you know, school. and everything like that. My daughter was still in primary school, so I was still doing school pick-up and balancing, working in the school as well. So that first year was really tough. However, it paid dividend because it actually reduced the length of the course
是一位母亲，还要承担所有俱乐部和（你知道的）学校的承诺。以及诸如此类的一切。我女儿还在小学，所以我还要接送孩子放学，同时还要平衡在学校的工作。所以第一年真的很艰难。然而，它得到了回报，因为它确实缩短了课程的长度...
from six years to five years. It did mean I didn't get a summer break from it in that first year, but it did mean that I was able to complete the degree in five years, which I actually really recommend for anybody. If you can manage to do that, then I think that's really, really helpful to reduce it by year. Yeah, absolutely. So, and what stage are we at now? How long was it ago that you graduated from your OU degree?
从六年缩短到五年。这确实意味着我在第一年没有暑假，但也意味着我能够在五年内完成学位，实际上我真的向任何人推荐这一点。如果你能做到这一点，那么我认为通过减少一年来缩短时间真的、真的很受用。是的，绝对的。那么，我们现在处于什么阶段？你从开放大学学位毕业多久了？
So I started in 2018. I completed in June 2023, graduating in September, 2023. So it's been, we're coming up for, yeah, two, over two years now. Amazing. And what have you been doing since? So as soon as I had, I received my result, my classification, I worked really hard. I was very driven to achieving a first. And the reason I was so driven to achieving a first is I had watched, joined a webinar about clinical psychology and roots. into clinical psychology and at this point I knew nothing like I didn't even really know the difference between a clinical psychologist, a counselling psychologist, forensic, educational
所以我是在2018年开始的。我在2023年6月完成，2023年9月毕业。所以算下来，我们马上就要迎来（是的）两年，两年多了。太棒了。你之后一直在做什么？因此，一拿到我的成绩和学位等级，我就非常努力。我非常有动力去获得一等荣誉学位。我之所以如此有动力去获得一等荣誉学位，是因为我看过、参加过一个关于临床心理学及其发展路径的网络研讨会...
and I watched this webinar and I saw the success rate in terms of age and then it got to the 40s and it was I think it was less than 1% and it was really emphasised that how competitive it was and a first class degree was really quite important. So I made it my, really, my life's work really at the time to secure that first. So as soon as I had that confirmation that I'd received the first and I had my degree was all confirmed, I started applying for assistant psychologist roles within the local area. I had one interview quite quickly. I didn't get the job.
关于临床心理学的途径，在这一点上我一无所知——甚至不知道临床心理学家、咨询心理学家、法医心理学家、教育心理学家之间的区别...
I got some really lovely feedback. And the feedback I got was the applicant that we have recruited, had previous NHS experience a week, and that was evidence through the language that they used, that they'd worked within the NHS before. I then went again. I got another interview very quickly. And within a month, I had secured an assistant psychology post. And this was in our mental health support team. So working in schools. So actually, even though I didn't have that clinical NHS experience, the experience I'd gained through working within an education setting really placed me in a really good, strong position for that post,
我看了这个网络研讨会，我看到了按年龄划分的成功率，当年龄达到40多岁时，我想这个比例不到1%，并且重点强调了竞争是多么激烈，一等学位真的非常重要。所以我当时把这作为我毕生的工作去确保获得一等学位。因此，一旦我得到确认我获得了一等学位并且我的学位全部得到确认后，我便开始申请当地的助理心理学家职位。我很快就去面试了一次。我没有得到这份工作。
and I was really fortunate that I got that. Well, well done to you, and I know that when I chatted with Sam previously about kind of the barriers to progressing in psychology when you might be slightly older than the average applicant, that actually the salary of an AP role, typically at band four or band five, can keep people quite stuck from accessing that route. Because, of course, if you've got a family to support,
我真的觉得自己很幸运能得到这个机会。做得好，而且我知道，当我之前和萨姆聊到在心理学领域晋升的种种障碍时，比如你可能比平均申请者的年龄要稍大一些，事实上，助理心理学家（AP）职位的薪水（通常在第四级或第五级）会让人很难迈出这一步。因为当然了，如果你还要养家糊口，
that is not a massive salary in this day and age. And I'm guessing the police pension obviously helps subsidise that to make it more accessible for you. And I'm very pleased to hear that you've been able to do that. And I guess ultimately that's meant that you are now, you know, you've been able to apply to the doctorate in clinical psychology. I think I'm writing saying the first time and then you were successful and I've got on. So tell us about that process for you. So the process of becoming an AP in terms of salary that you've mentioned is really
在这个时代，那可不是一笔巨款。我猜警方的退休金显然有助于补贴这部分收入，让你更容易承担得起。我非常高兴听到你能够做到这一点。我想归根结底，这意味着你现在，你知道的，你已经能够申请临床心理学博士学位了。我想我没记错的话，你第一次申请就成功了，并且被录取了。那么，给我们讲讲你的这个心路历程吧。你刚才提到的作为一名助理心理学家在薪资方面的问题真的是
problematic and it's something I feel quite passionate about actually. I'm very fortunate. I have a husband who brings in a good income and alongside my police pension, I could supplement my salary with my pension. I could top it up. Had I have been an old applicant with children, it would have been impossible. You cannot survive on it. I think I worked it out. It's something like £12 an hour. I could have got paid more in Audi, working in Audi or Liddle. At the time, I think they were paying £13 an hour. So it's really difficult. It's extremely problematic, and again, it closes that route off to so many people that are not in that privileged position to be able to do that. And something needs to change, and that's something when I am qualified, and I feel that my voice can be heard a little more, that I would like to advocate, in particular, older entrants, APs.
非常棘手，这也是我深感热情的一个问题。我非常幸运，我有一个收入很好的丈夫，再加上我的警察退休金，我可以用退休金来补贴我的薪水。我可以把钱凑够。如果我是一个有孩子的年长申请者，那将是不可能的。你靠那点钱根本无法生存。我想我算过，大概是每小时12英镑。我在奥乐齐（Audi）或利多（Lidl）工作挣的可能会更多。当时，我想他们的时薪是13英镑。所以这真的很困难，极其棘手，而且再次说明，它将许多没有处于那种特权地位、无法做到这一点的人挡在了这条道路之外。有些事情必须改变，这是当我有资格、当我觉得自己的声音能被更多人听到时，我特别想为之发声的，特别是针对年长的入行者和助理心理学家。
The majority of APs I work with, they do still live at home. So it is accessible to go on that band four wage. But there is absolutely no progression, like you say. Band 5 AP roles are non-existent, certainly within the trust that I currently work in. There aren't Band 4, Band 5 roles anymore. So you're really stuck. And unlike the other banding,
与我合作的大多数助理心理学家，他们仍然和父母住在一起。所以拿着第四级的薪资还是可以活下去的。但正如你所说，绝对没有任何晋升空间。第五级的助理心理学家职位根本不存在，至少在我目前工作的信托基金里是这样。再也没有第四级和第五级的职位了。所以你真的被卡住了。而且与其他薪级不同，
whereby you move to the next increment after two years, for Band 4 it's three. So you really are very, very stuck. in that role. Yeah, thank you for talking to us about that. And I hope it didn't feel kind of too prying. But I know it is a really important conversation. And yeah, like if we really want to advocate for diversity in our workforce,
两年后你可以晋升到下一个薪档，但第四级需要三年。所以你真的非常非常被困在这个职位上。是的，谢谢你跟我们聊起这些。我希望这听起来没有显得太过于窥探隐私。但我知道这确实是一个非常重要的对话。而且，是的，如果我们真的想倡导我们员工队伍的多样性，
like it matters, doesn't it? And, you know, we don't want people in a position where they're having to go to the bank and saying, can I have a loan to support me to be an assistant psychologist? Because ultimately I'll be able to pay that back hopefully when I'm, when I'm a qualified psych. Like, that's not how we want to be getting diversity in our workforce. So tell us then about what came next, you know? So from that one AP role, have you then applied to the doctorate in clinical psychology?
这很重要，不是吗？而且，你知道的，我们不希望人们陷入这样一种境地：他们不得不去银行说，我能贷个款来支持我成为一名助理心理学家吗？因为最终我希望当我成为一名合格的心理学家时，我能把钱还上。这可不是我们在员工队伍中实现多样性的方式。那么，给我们讲讲接下来发生了什么吧？从那个助理心理学家职位开始，你接着申请了临床心理学博士学位吗？
I knew that before I could apply, I needed 12 months experience, clinical experience, which prior to entering the NHS, I didn't have. So initially, I thought, great, I will graduate and I will apply that year. and that will start the process. And then somebody told me the reality. And I was very much, oh, okay. So then I had to accept I was going to be an AP on a ban for wage for a minimum of two years. And I got my head around that through thinking that it would be an investment.
我知道在申请之前，我需要12个月的经验，临床经验，而在进入NHS之前，我并没有这些经验。所以最初，我想，太好了，我会毕业，并在那一年申请，然后这将开始这个过程。然后有人告诉我现实。我当时的感觉是，哦，好吧。所以后来我不得不接受这样一个事实：我将在接下来的至少两年里，拿着第四级的薪资担任助理心理学家。我通过把它当作一项投资，来调整好了自己的心态。
I was investing. This was a stepping stone and it would require some investing. So I worked within the mental health support. team as an AP. I worked beyond my remit. I went a little bit further. I brought over my passion for reducing male suicide based on the experiences I'd had with attempted and completed male suicides into this service. It was clear from the outset. There was a huge disparity between the number of boys and girls being referred into the service for low mood and anxiety. And I really wanted to understand why that was. With male suicide, the leading cause of death in men under the age of 50,
我在投资。这是一块垫脚石，它需要一些投资。所以我作为一名助理心理学家在心理健康支援团队工作。我的工作超出了我的职责范围。我走得更远了一点。我把我根据自己经历过的男性自杀未遂和已遂事件而产生的减少男性自杀的热情带入了这项服务中。从一开始就很明显。转介到该服务因情绪低落和焦虑而接受帮助的男孩和女孩的数量之间存在着巨大的差距。我真的很想了解这是为什么。在男性自杀中，50岁以下男性的头号死因是，
for me it was blatantly obvious that we needed to be targeting boys at a younger age to break down those barriers and stigmas, enable them to feel safe and secure to access mental health support at a much earlier stage. And to recognise the signs of poor mental health, which I think is something that still needs a lot of work. So I started a quality improvement project and I based it in a school and that project really did give me a springboard into my career. I had a very unique opportunity I had to present the findings of my project to the trust executive board of directors. I was able to increase the number of referrals from this school from 4% for boys. up to 50% by between January of 2024 and November of 2024.
对我来说，显而易见的是，我们需要在更小的年龄就针对男孩采取行动，以打破这些障碍和污名化，让他们能够在更早的阶段感到安全和安心，从而获得心理健康支持。并认识到心理健康状况不佳的迹象，我认为这仍然是一项需要大量工作的事情。所以我发起了一个质量改进项目，我把它设在一所学校里，那个项目确实为我的职业生涯提供了一个跳板。我有一个非常独特的机遇，我必须向信托基金执行董事会展示我的项目成果。在2024年1月到2024年11月期间，我成功地将该学校男孩的转介率从4%提高到了50%。
So in that short space of time. I did that through a number of routes, including boy-only assemblies to raise awareness of mental health in which I invited a guest speaker from Health Watch Essex who had lived experience of mental health. I've developed a boys' participation group to have so that the boys could be heard and they could shape the service they receive. And that gave me an awful lot of really valuable experience that I could use as evidence for my doctorate application, which was really helpful. And that's something I really advocate any APs. Go beyond your role and your remit.
所以在那个短时间内。我是通过多种途径做到这一点的，包括举办纯男孩集会来提高心理健康意识，在会上我邀请了一位来自埃塞克斯健康观察（Health Watch Essex）的具有心理健康生活经验的演讲嘉宾。我成立了一个男孩参与小组，以便让男孩们的声音被听到，并让他们塑造他们所接受的服务。这给了我大量非常宝贵的经验，我可以将其用作博士申请的证据，这真的很有帮助。这也是我强烈推荐给任何助理心理学家的做法。超越你的角色和职责范围。
look to do something different, such as a quality improvement project. We know that we go and we do clinical service audits and we'll look at data, but see what more you can do, because I truly believe that that work that I did, which is work that I would like to continue as part of my thesis, if that is I'm allowed to do so, that work really did provide me with that additional evidence that I needed to demonstrate that I was ready for the doctorate. Yeah, and it sounds like such an important piece of work and well done to you for kind of reducing that disparity
寻找做一些不同事情的机会，比如质量改进项目。我们知道我们会去进行临床服务审计并查看数据，但看看你还能做些什么，因为我坚信我所做的那项工作（如果允许的话，这也是我希望作为我的论文的一部分继续做下去的工作），确实为我提供了额外的证据，证明我已准备好攻读博士学位。是的，听起来这是一项非常重要的工作，为你缩小这种差距做得很好，
in kind of gender referrals to actually make it equitable 50-50 boys and girls. Like that's, you know, really important. And I'm kind of just going to point out that the episode before this one with Jack Lowe for our watchers and our listeners is kind of about kind of making the most of the experiences you find yourself in. And we talk about something called kind of job crafting, which is exactly what you've just spoken about, kind of trying to really maximize your opportunities for learning and growth.
在性别转介方面做到公平，男女各占50-50。这真的很重要。我顺便指出一下，我们这一集之前的上一集，杰克·洛（Jack Lowe）的那一集，对于我们的观众和听众来说，主要是关于如何充分利用你所处的经历。我们讨论了一种叫做“工作重塑”（job crafting）的概念，这正是你刚才所说的，试图真正最大化你的学习和成长机会。
So if people want to learn more about that and haven't already watched or listened to the episode with Jack, please do check that episode out as well. So you got all this kind of on a form, you know, you were happy with your form, you clicked, submit, it? Then what happened? Then I changed jobs. So I stayed within the mental health support team beyond the 12 months purely because I wanted to see through the quality improvement project. So I stayed in the end, I think it was 19 months. So longer than anticipated. However, I click
所以，如果人们想了解更多关于这方面的信息，并且还没看过或听过杰克那一集的，请务必去看看那一集。所以你把所有这些都填进了一份表格里，你知道的，你对你的表格很满意，你点击了提交，对吧？然后发生了什么？然后我换了工作。我留在心理健康支援团队超过了12个月，纯粹是因为我想把质量改进项目做完。所以我最后留了，我想是19个月。所以比预期的要长。然而，我点击了
submit and thought, okay, I'm either going to get on this year or I'm not. The last, likelihood is I'm not. The odds are stacked against me because we know the statistics, we know the ratio, and we know the chances of getting on first time are really, really slim. So I need another role. If I'm going to apply a second time, I need a different position in a different service to show that I am expanding my skills and I'm able to diversify it and work within another setting. So I applied for a number assistant psychologist roles within Essex where I live and within London as well. I was really lucky once again. I had an interview with an eating disorder service based in Barking, covering Barkin and Dagenham, Waltham Forest, Redbridge
提交并心想，好吧，我今年能被录取或者不能。最后的可能性是我不会被录取。胜算对我不利，因为我们知道统计数据，我们知道比例，我们也知道第一次被录取的几率非常非常渺茫。所以我需要另一个职位。如果我要申请第二次，我需要在不同服务部门担任不同的职位，以展示我正在扩展我的技能，并且我有能力将其多样化并在另一个环境中工作。所以我申请了几个在我居住的埃塞克斯以及伦敦的助理心理学家职位。我再次非常幸运。我获得了位于巴金（Barking）、涵盖伦敦巴金和达根汉姆（Dagenham）、沃尔瑟姆森林（Waltham Forest）、雷德布里奇（Redbridge）
and Havering, boroughs of London. And in April of this year, I joined the intensive support pathway of the CAMS section of the eating disorders service. So I've been working as as an AP now since April. I did break the news prior to starting. Great news for me. But I said, you know, for full transparency, they knew that I had applied. I was very opening interview I had applied. I said for full transparency, I have been offered a place and I have accepted. So my time here will be short but I you know I will give it everything 100% and they wanted some support with setting up a quality improvement project which is ongoing at the moment so they were still keen for me to go which I was really relieved about because actually I was really excited at getting that experience so
和海弗林（Havering）等伦敦行政区的饮食失调服务机构的面试机会。今年4月，我加入了饮食失调服务机构CAMS部门的强化支持通道。所以我从4月开始就一直担任助理心理学家。我在开始之前确实透露了这个消息。对我来说是个好消息。但我说，你知道的，为了完全透明，他们知道我已经申请了。我在面试时非常坦诚地说我申请过了。我说为了完全透明，我已经拿到了一份Offer并且我已经接受了。所以我在公司的时间会很短，但我知道我会100%全力以赴，他们需要一些支持来建立一个目前正在进行中的质量改进项目，所以他们仍然渴望我去，这让我松了一口气，因为实际上我对获得这种经验感到非常兴奋，所以
from April until I start on the 1st of October I'm in the eating disorder service and the experience is incomparable to anything that I've ever done before. Having that physical health component, the assistant psychologist role, is so valuable. I feel like a nurse. I do blood pressure. I do the way in the blood's temperature. And I really enjoy that physical health aspect. I work really closely with psychiatrists, clinical.
从4月到我10月1日开始，我一直在饮食失调服务部门工作，这段经验与我以前做过的任何事情都无法比拟。拥有这种身体健康方面的成分，即助理心理学家的角色，是如此宝贵。我觉得自己像个护士。我测血压。我测量体重和血液温度。我真的很享受这个身体健康方面的工作。我与精神科医生、临床
psychologist, psychotherapists, really, really experienced clinical nurse specialists. And I feel so fortunate to have been able to have these five months within that service. So that is what I did. So after I click submit, that's what I initially did. And that's worked out well. It has. But I do want to shift your narrative perspective slightly because you keep telling us that you're lucky. You're very skilled. You're a strong applicant and you deserve to be here. You have had a successful, long career as a police sergeant and all that that entails with working with offenders, working probably closely with families as well and staff teams and kind of the police organisation as a whole. Also, you've applied yourself very, very firmly and strongly in your OU degree. And you've
心理学家、心理治疗师以及经验非常非常丰富的临床专科护士紧密合作。我觉得自己非常幸运，能够在那个服务部门度过这五个月。这就是我所做的。所以在我点击提交之后，我最初就是这么做的。结果挺不错的。确实如此。但我确实想稍微改变一下你的叙事视角，因为你一直告诉我们你很幸运。你非常有技术。你是一个强有力的申请者，你理应来到这里。你作为一名警长有着成功且漫长的职业生涯，其中涉及与罪犯打交道、可能也与家庭以及员工团队和整个警察组织紧密合作。此外，你在开放大学（OU）的学位上也非常非常坚定和努力地应用了自己。并且你
got a first and you've gone above and beyond in every role you've done and done that job crafting but also you know you haven't thought right well I've clicked submit I'll just wait and see you've thought well how can I make myself an even stronger applicant so I've got maybe something else extra to talk about interview or you know or just more strings to my bow for next time you deserve to be here Claire and I'm so excited for your future cohort who who gets police sergeant, you know, background and expertise, who gets, you know, someone that's a mummy to probably quite grown up people now. So you've come through the education system, who is married and all that that entails, who likely has her own experience of grief,
获得了最高荣誉学位（First），并且在你做过的每一个角色中都超越了自我，做到了工作重塑，而且你知道的，你并没有想过“好吧，既然我点击了提交，我就坐等结果吧”，你一直在思考“我怎样才能让自己成为一个更有力的申请者，这样我可能在面试时有额外的东西可以谈论，或者你知道的，只是为下一次准备更多的大招”。克莱尔，你理应来到这里，我为你未来的同龄人感到非常兴奋，他们能得到一位拥有警长背景和专业知识的人，他们能得到一位可能是相当成年的人的妈妈的人。所以你经历了教育系统，你已经结婚并拥有这一切所带来的一切，你可能拥有自己关于悲伤、
loss, friendships, but also applying yourself and holding yourself accountable and self-actualising, I would say you are not lucky. You are an incredibly strong candidate and that the doctorate course are lucky to have you. Thank you. I think we experience imposter syndrome quite a lot, don't we? I remember getting the first AP role and being told it can take years to get your first AP role. I had a 10-year plan. My 10-year plan was I started by degree at the age of 40 in 2018. my tenure plan worked like this. Okay, so six years for the degree. That was initially. One year clinical experience, three years doctorate, and I will qualify at 50. I then brought that down to five years and then I had that realization that actually it would be two years before I could start the doctorate once I started to get clinical, but I'd have to get on first time. So this 10-year plan was going to be tough. I got the first, I secured my AP role literally within a few
失落、友谊的经历，同时也应用了自己并承担责任和实现自我，我会说你一点也不幸运。你是一个非常强大的候选人，博士课程能拥有你，是他们的幸运。谢谢。我觉得我们经常经历冒名顶替综合征，对吧？我记得得到第一个助理心理学家职位时，有人告诉我，要获得第一个助理心理学家职位可能需要数年时间。我有一个10年计划。我的10年计划是，我在2018年40岁时开始攻读学位。我的十年计划是这样的。好吧，学位需要六年。这最初是这样的。一年临床经验，三年博士学位，我将在50岁时获得资格。然后我把它缩短到五年，然后我意识到实际上自我获得临床经验开始，需要两年时间才能开始攻读博士学位，但我必须一次性被录取。所以这个10年计划将是艰难的。我拿到了第一个职位，在拿到学位最终成绩的几
weeks of getting my final result for the degree. And I remember on my first day, going into my trust, and I work for a wonderful trust, NELFD, North East London Foundation Trust. I'm picking up my badge and seeing the words, assistant psychologist on my ID badge and feeling so proud, so chuffed. Going in and on my first day, I met with my team and I worked with some wonderful people in mental health sport team. But there was this one individual who was a band five at the time, so not a senior. And she said to me in front of everybody, I don't mean to be rude, but you're only a band four. What could you actually do? And at that point, my bubble burst and that realization hit me, I'm only a band four.
周内，我就literally拿到了我的助理心理学家职位。我记得在第一天，我走进我的信托基金，我为之工作的信托基金很棒，叫NELFD，即东北伦敦基金会信托基金（North East London Foundation Trust）。我拿着我的胸卡，看到我的ID胸卡上的“助理心理学家”这几个字，感到无比自豪，无比高兴。走进办公室，在第一天，我见到了我的团队，我和心理健康支援团队的一些优秀的人一起工作。但当时有这样一个人，她当时是第五级，所以不是高级员工。她在所有人面前对我说，我不是故意冒犯，但你只是个第四级。你到底能做什么？就在那一刻，我的泡沫破裂了，那个现实击中了我，我只是个第四级。
And I've been fighting against that psychologically ever since. And I think that's why I probably on reflection used terms such as lucky. I've been called out a few times for saying I'm only a band four. And my colleagues and my seniors have said, Claire, you're not, you're not only a band for you're so much more than a band for you're so different to any assistant psychologist we've ever had you need to stop saying you're only a band for and i i would second that but also you know a question that i'll often ask someone in a trauma service is how much of that that person said to you do you need to hold on to and how much can you let go that comment has driven me and after my bubble
从那以后，我在心理上一直在与这种想法作斗争。我想这就是为什么我在回顾时可能会使用“幸运”这样的词汇。我曾几次被人指出我不应该说我“只是个第四级”。我的同事和高级同事曾对我说：“克莱尔，你不是，你不仅仅是个第四级，你比第四级多得多，你跟我们见过的任何助理心理学家都不一样，你需要停止说你只是个第四级。”而我，我对此表示赞同，但同时，你知道的，我在创伤服务中经常问某人的一个问题是：那个人对你所说的话，有多少是你需要放在心上的，又有多少是你可以放下的？那句评论一直激励着我，在我的泡沫
it lit a fire in my belly and yes I am currently a band five I'm going to be a band six I'm going to leap I'm going to be that band six and then on qualification going to be a band seven within 12 months I'll be an eight a and my aim is a band nine I want to be making I want to be an executive director I want to be making fundamental changes and improvements within the NHS within the trust. From a band fort, I have battled to make those changes. To me, it's so clear what we need to do for example in schools to reduce male suicide. Let's start with the younger generation now. But as a band four, I just don't have that network. I don't have that connections, authority, but that comment really drove me. And that's
破灭之后，它在我心中点燃了一把火，是的，我现在是第五级，我要成为第六级，我要跨越，我要成为那个第六级，然后在获得资格后，将在12个月内成为第七级，我会成为第八A级，我的目标是第九级。我想做出改变，我想成为执行董事，我想在NHS内部、在信托基金内部做出根本性的变革和改进。从第四级开始，我一直在努力做出这些改变。对我来说，我们在学校里需要做些什么来减少男性自杀，这是显而易见的。让我们从现在的年轻一代开始。但作为第四级，我根本没有那个网络。我没有那些人脉、权威，但那句评论确实激励了我。那是
something that I, I belong to a number of AP forums. And APs often feel very demanding. moralised by how they're regarded. People don't have an understanding of the skills that they bring. And I use that story a lot. Let that bring fire in your belly. One day, I will supervise that clinician and I will remind her what she told me. And I will ask never, never to repeat that and never say that to anybody else that is on their way up. You are a force to be reckoned with and I am excited to see how you thrive and how you grow. And please do keep us posted. If you've got any kind of last advice for someone listening to this who've maybe not feeling that maybe their time has ticked past for them or that they, you know, they've been burned by people
有些事情我，我属于几个助理心理学家论坛。助理心理学家经常因为他们受到的对待而感到士气低落。人们不理解他们带来的技能。我经常讲这个故事。让那团火在你心中燃烧吧。有一天，我会监督那个临床医生，我会提醒她她对我说过的话。我会要求她永远、永远不要重复那句话，永远不要对任何其他正在晋升路上的人说这样的话。你是一股不可忽视的力量，我很高兴看到你的繁荣和成长。请随时向我们通报最新情况。如果你对任何正在听这个节目的人有什么最后的建议，他们可能觉得自己的时间已经流逝了，或者他们觉得，你知道的，他们曾被别人伤害过
that have made them feel that they can't do this. What would you say, Claire? This is a long, hard process, like to become a clinical psychologist, I think is actually longer than to become a medical doctor. I think it takes longer. It has to be your passion, your dream. You have to be motivated. You have to really, really, really want it. If you don't, I don't think it's necessarily the right path for you. But if you do, then never give up. I have a friend who I've met through AP forums. We worked on a AP community of practice together with the psychology professions, psychological professions network, the PPN. She got on this year after seven attempts. She's also an older applicant. She has children. And this was her seventh year and she's got on.
这让他们觉得他们无法做到这一点。克莱尔，你会怎么说？这是一个漫长而艰难的过程，比如成为一名临床心理学家，我认为实际上比成为一名内科医生还要长。我认为这需要更长的时间。这必须是你的激情、你的梦想。你必须有动力。你必须非常、非常、非常渴望它。如果你不想，我认为这不一定是适合你的道路。但如果你想，那就永远不要放弃。我有一个通过AP论坛认识的朋友。我们和心理学专业、心理专业网络（PPN）一起在一个AP实践社区工作。她在第七次尝试后今年考上了。她也是一个年龄较大的申请人。她有孩子。这是她的第七年，她考上了。
So if that's what you really want, then just, just don't give up. Be really, really focused. And look beyond the undergrad. Look beyond the band for and the future. And that's what I've always held in mind. So when I'm feeling really demoralized, really undervalued, I hold that in mind. I hold that. And when I got that email to say, been offered a place, I cannot begin to describe how how that felt. It was unreal that I got that. I got one shot. I got one interview, one shot, and I knew everything was waging on that. The other three, I didn't get an interview. I wasn't shortlisted. So I had one shot. I was my true authentic self in interview. Everybody told me to be. I thought, I don't think that's good enough. On the day, I decided I
所以如果这就是你真正想要的，那就不要放弃。要非常、非常专注。眼光要超越本科。眼光要超越第四阶段和未来。这就是我一直铭记在心的。所以当我感到非常沮丧、非常不被重视时，我把这些记在心里。我牢记这一点。当我收到那封说被录取的电子邮件时，我无法开始形容那是什么感觉。我被录取了，这太不真实了。我只有一次机会。我只有一次面试，一次机会，我知道一切都押在那上面。另外三个，我没有得到面试机会。我没有进入候选名单。所以我只有一次机会。我在面试中表现出了真实的我。每个人都告诉我该怎么做。我想，我觉得这还不够。在那天，我决定我
would be and it's paid off. Just don't, don't give up and it's never, ever, ever too late to change career. I will qualify at 50. I have no plans to retire. I've got friends my age that's talking about winding down. I'm winding up and I will continue working for as long as my brain will allow me to cognitively continue working and I'll be working within the NHS as well. And I'm super excited. Amazing. Hats off to you and many, many congratulations, but this is not, this is not a fluke. This is not a fluke. You absolutely have earned your stripes and you deserve to be there. You deserve to be here and I'm excited to see how you grow. So please do stay in touch with this. Thank you so much. I will do. And thanks for having me on. Oh, you're so welcome.
会去做，而且得到了回报。千万、千万不要放弃，而且改变职业永远、永远、永远不会太晚。我将在50岁时获得资格。我没有退休的计划。我的同龄朋友都在谈论放慢脚步。我在加速前进，只要我的大脑允许我继续在认知上工作，我就会继续工作，我也将在NHS内部工作。我超级兴奋。太棒了。向你致敬，并致以千万分的祝贺，但这绝不是侥幸。这绝对不是侥幸。你绝对是通过努力赢得了荣誉，你理应在那里。你理应在这里，我很高兴看到你的成长。所以请务必与我们保持联系。非常感谢。我会的。也谢谢邀请我。哦，不用客气。
Lovely to getting to chat with you. It's been a real privilege. Have a beautiful rest of summer. and hope that your training goes well. Thank you. What an absolutely brilliant episode that was, what a real privilege to speak to Claire. And if you like me think that Claire is an incredibly capable applicant, please do give her some love in the comments on YouTube. And if you're seeing this content on social media, please do like, comment and share to help it reach the widest audience possible. If you are able to rate or subscribe to shows or follow creators that you really rate, that really is the kindest thing you can do. So please do do that if you love the content that I create here. If you've got any ideas for future episodes, please don't be a
很高兴能和你聊天。这真是一种特权。祝你剩下的夏天过得愉快，并希望你的培训顺利。谢谢。这真是一集精彩绝伦的节目，能与克莱尔对话真是一种特权。如果你和我一样认为克莱尔是一个能力非凡的申请者，请在YouTube的评论区给她一些爱。如果你在社交媒体上看到这个内容，请点赞、评论和分享，以帮助它传达给尽可能广泛的受众。如果你能给节目评分、订阅或关注你真正欣赏的创作者，那真的是你能做的最贴心的事。所以如果你喜欢我在这里创作的内容，请务必这样做。如果你对未来的剧集有什么想法，请不要
stranger. Please do come and connect with me on my social media where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you are an aspiring psychologist and you are thinking that it's your time and you're ready for the next step, but perhaps you don't have the requisite, you know, support, guidance, nurturance, things to help you stretch your own development, then please do consider joining us in the aspiring psychologist membership community, which gets wonderful reviews and which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And then, of course, if you are ready for something a little bit more intensive and a little bit more time with me, please do consider the Ready to Rise program, which is just the biggest pleasure to run. And that means that you get
生疏。请来我的社交媒体与我联系，我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。如果你是一个有抱负的心理学家，并且你认为这是你的时代，你已经准备好迎接下一步，但也许你没有必要的（你知道的）支持、指导、滋养、帮助你拓展自身发展的东西，那么请考虑加入我们有抱负的心理学家会员社区，它获得了极好的评价，你可以以每月仅30英镑的价格加入，且没有最低期限。然后，当然，如果你准备好接受更密集、与我有更多相处时间的课程，请考虑“准备崛起”项目，运行这个项目是莫大的荣幸。
12 one-to-one sessions with me across a year plus a load of other great benefits too, which you can check out in the description on YouTube for this video or in the show notes on social media or if you click any of my link tree bios, you'll find the information for the membership and for ready to rise there. Please do come and grab your free psychology success guide from my website www. Aspiring hyphen Psychologist.comco.
一年内有12次与我的一对一辅导，还有许多其他巨大的福利，你可以在本视频YouTube描述中的节目简介或社交媒体上查看，或者如果你点击我的任何链接树个人简介，你就会在那里找到会员资格和准备崛起的信息。请务必从我的网站www. Aspiring hyphen Psychologist.comco.获取你的免费心理学成功指南。
com. UK. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful, and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book,
com. UK。嗨，我叫艾米莉。我是南安普顿大学研究临床心理学的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人对他们旅程的反思是如此富有启发性，它让我对自己的旅程和技能进行了很多反思。它也有助于客看待事物，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，也没关系。我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣，
however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. You know, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然而，每个人的旅程都是如此鼓舞人心。每天早晨以这些故事作为我的动力，真是太愉快了。我几乎很不舍得迎来结束。你知道的，这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。